[Applaudissements]
d'où l'idée les angels the man from
merde
non mais attendez temps direct
vous savez je crois pas qu'il y ait de
bonnes mauvaises situations ce que tu
appelles une benne c'est une pompe à
fric oui je sais bien que c'est moche
mais comment résister d'habitude je
résiste mais là non je vous assure que
ça m'intéresse vraiment c'est parce
qu'on a rarement l'occasion de
rencontrer un bourreau dans sa vie c'est
vrai quand ça arrive à ce soit la
dernière fois
est ce que l'un d'entre vous peut me
dire là dans les yeux qu'il a déjà
commencé un spectacle ici sans avoir été
payés jusqu'au dernier centime à part
toi
alors voilà alors mais je pense pas
michel j'ai profité cet hôtel depuis qu
elle est un peu péché c'est la tradition
cadreuse bonsoir connu les angels
bienvenue dans l'univers magique des ja
du 62e festival de cannes
allez c'est parti on ne peut plus qu'à
laisser partir moi je vous imaginez
courant nu dans des champs de lotus
foule l'émotion
my body chez king of joy au festival où
vont les heureux du jour où vont les
cadors les nantis où vont les smokings
où vont les bijoux où vont les coiffures
lac et où vont ses jambes interminables
avec personne au goût je sais plus du
tout ce que je voulais dire parce que
c'est juste voilà typiquement ce qui est
un manque de travail
je suis triste que ça se termine en mai
peut-être et changer de numéro de
téléphone ou des adresses pour vous voir
et on va y penser ça les moyens de
pardon très pratique tu resté groupé
soir pour remettre la caméra d'or jument
de d'accueillir isabelle adjani
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je me suis trompé je me suis
trompé de toute façon on ne peut pas
faire ça trois années de suite ont comme
on dit dans le métier ça c'est fait je
vous demandais à la gentillesse de
déclarer le festival ouvert tout ce que
vous voudrez mais juste stable après des
choses au bistrot avec moi sur votre vie
privée
bonsoir bon festival bonne soirée bonne
vie skis après merci beaucoup
[Musique]